le trampo le trampo le
trampauispo alors Nabila va devoir
éclater des ballons dans lesquels il y a
des phrases de chansons de Pascal Obispo
c'est vous qui allez animé le jeu
jeanluc exactement il y a des extraits
de vos chansons que vous avez chanté ou
écrit pour les autres donc elle va
sauter elle va percer des ballon je vous
donne la phrase le premier qui sait à
quelle chanson ça se rapporte il appuie
sur le faut la chanter hein faut la
chanter il appuie sur le buzer d'abord
je donne la main et celui qui a appuyé
doit la chanter et marque un point s'il
a vraiment la chansonord d'accord je
rappelle que c'est des chansons de
Pascal Obispo qui est là donc
normalement il a un petit avantage sur
lég avantage Ren compr magnifque ou
c'est no ah oui ça c'est vrai Nabil
c'est pas grave si vous n'avez rien
compris vous inquiétez pas on l' bien on
l'a bien compris attention c'est parti
éclater un un premier ballon naabil il
faut que vous soyez centré sur le
trampoline ouais par que Sin on vair un
accident sinon on va avoir un accident
alors
attention rebondir s bien cette séence
la S bien rebond mais mais pourquo oh là
là mais c'est pas possible pour
[Applaudissements]
ça la parole la prère
par écoutez bien c'est le premier qui
tape alors c'est quoi bleu marine et
Blue sous le soleil ble marine et Blue
ah oui c'est sous le
soleilter
so
blue malin mais il a perdou pareil
jusqu'à on oublie tout trop tard le
point va pas ah oui mais je peux je peux
pr à on l'a pas dit
[Applaudissements]
çaz
attention
allez allez mais éc des ballons alors
[Musique]
oubl faut pas oublier les ballons c'est
super ce que tu fais mais vise les
ballons quand même ok allez on y va Lab
m'amuse trop allez mais ou
[__] ta mère la
[__] mais c'est quoi Lab là-bas là-bas
là-bas c'est quoi là-bas là-bas ah j'ai
envie de mourir j'ai envie de mourir
c'est quoi ah j'ai envie de mourir ça me
dégoûte sur la sur la ça me dégoûte ab
c'est rien c'est
rien c'est quoi cette
[Applaudissements]
merde la V la va c'est rien c'est des
haricots c'est rien du tout c'est des
haricots mais c'est des haricots ça me
dé mais mangé de haricots
non connaissez pasic
Matias
[Applaudissements]
allez-y Nabila remontez Nabila remonter
c'est des haricots mais just tu peux
marcher mais ça va pas les faire
sécher je s alors vous écoutez je sens
qu'on ti un truc là tu
tomber je vais mourir sens pas bien je
vais
canner qu j'en peux plus allez allez
vous m'z attention c'est peut-être le
dernier il 1-0 pour Pascal attention
pour ce bonheur en prime que tu m'as
donné c'est moi c'est moi Pascal qui
appuyé non je vous jure que c moi le
prier s allumé Pascal c'est quoi la
chanson mésim je mon mésim ou mais il
faut la chanter maintenant il faut la
chanter sinon c'est c'est quel point tu
m' mis les ma plus belle année pour ce
bonheur en prime que tu m'as donné je
suis à
[Rires]
jamais c'est ça être p
[Applaudissements]
bravo j'adore parce que en régie c'est
la première fois qu'il lance les titres
alors que le gars est là il vient de le
chanter le mec est là parce là on a même
pas besoin de le lancer c'est un peu
votre souffre douleur j'ai l'impression
pas du
toutb on t'adore arrête allez
[Applaudissements]
Lab non attention elle a fa ma mère il a
un truc ch non je crois la tête de ma
mère qui a un truc très bizarre dans
la la mer
c'est éclatez aut éclate
autr chou vise Mo
ou c'est parti c'est peut-être le trè
point pour Pascal et sera g ma vie sur
ma vie ne regarde
[Applaudissements]
pas bravo
bravo allez
attention c ça peut se jouer là-dessus
c'est quoi ma maison m'a tourfelle c'est
cy qui a le point ouais je suis tomber
pour elle on vous
écoute je suis ma maison ma tour
est car
lesau l oiseau je suus
desmaré
z allez encore la partie essenti de la
ch compris ta question il y a de NAB il
en faut encore
[Applaudissements]
un
allezb alors c'est très grave ce qui se
passe ici
hein
c'est très
très rigole pour alors
ouais ouais
alors ça va alors on la joue on la joue
pas on la joue attention on se concentre
c'est de la f l'existence et les roses
se fanent même à lundi j'ai pas endu
l'existence et les roses se fanent même
un lundi
l'exist Pascal personne ne te remplace
non personne ou c'est
pas
[Applaudissements]
pas Pascal merci Pascal PASC on va vous
faire un petit bisou Pascal va vous
faire un petit bisou ça va vous faire du
bien Pascalis mer un petit bisou àb
quand même elle est pas bien
VZ
merci merci voilà
voilà ah ça va ça va je rappelle Pascal
Obispo la sortie de M bien sûr et Pascal
Obispo est en tourné dans toute la
France et bien sûr le single événement
Kiss And Love Pascal merci d'avoir été
avec nous mon Pascal un gros bisou mon
Pascal merci d'avoir été là pascalourn
dans tout laance applaudissement pour
Pascal
PASC merci mon chéri t'embrasse merci
mon Pascal Pascal qui est avec
merci Pascal
Pascal Pascal Pascal Pascal Pascal
Pascal Pascal merci Pascal aup est avec
nous ça va nabida E nabida alors
attention juste un petit truc j'ai
entendu des choses un petit peu
vulgaires quand vous étiez sur le TR
j'ai dit quoi non non j'ai entendu on
perè ça perd hippopète faut dire ça
parce que c'est c'est fini là mots comme
ça j'ai entendu des j'ai entendu des
mots pas bien j'ai pas aimé je vous le
dis j'ai pas
[Musique]
aimé